About 21 million adults in the U.S. suffer from depression. For some of them, the first-line treatments of therapy and antidepressant drugs don't help. So what can they do? In recent years, another treatment option has emerged, transcranial magnetic stimulation, or TMS, which uses high-powered magnets to stimulate electrical activity in targeted areas of the brain and can alleviate or put into remission people's treatment-resistant depression. Brain stimulation treatments, including TMS, are not new, but in recent years they've become more effective and more available, and TMS has earned the approval of the U.S. Food and Drug
在美国，约有2100万成年人患有抑郁症。对于其中一些人来说，药物治疗和心理咨询等一线治疗方法并无效果。那么他们该怎么办呢？近年来，一种新的治疗选择应运而生，即经颅磁刺激（TMS）。它利用高功率磁铁刺激大脑特定区域的电活动，可以缓解甚至治愈人们的难治性抑郁症。包括TMS在内的大脑刺激疗法并非新鲜事物，但近年来它们变得更加有效且更易获得，TMS也已获得了美国食品药品监督管理局的批准。那么它是如何工作的呢？
Administration. So how does it work? What is happening in the brain during TMS treatments? What mental health disorders can it treat? Only depression, or does it work for, say, anxiety? Who is it most useful for? Are there people who should not try it? And are there side effects? Who can administer it and what other types of brain stimulation treatments are researchers investigating? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
在TMS治疗过程中大脑发生了什么？它可以治疗哪些心理健康疾病？仅限于抑郁症，还是对焦虑症也有效？它对谁最有用？有哪些人不应该尝试？有副作用吗？谁可以进行这种治疗？研究人员还在探索哪些其他类型的大脑刺激疗法？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是莎拉·利森比博士，她是一位精神病学家，也是美国国家心理健康研究所非侵入性神经调节部门的主任及转化研究部主任。
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Our first is Dr. Sarah Lysenby, a Psychological, psychiatrist and the director of the non-invasive neuromodulation unit and director of the Division of Translational Research at the National Institutes of Mental Health. Dr. Lisenby's research focuses on brain stimulation interventions for treating depression. She has led pioneering work in areas including transcranial magnetic stimulation, electroconvulsive therapy, and magnetic seizure therapy. Before joining NIMH, she was chair of the Duke University Department of Psychiatry and Behaviorary. Sciences, and founded and directed both the Duke University and Columbia University divisions of brain stimulation. She has published more than 280 scientific papers and received numerous
利森比博士的研究重点是治疗抑郁症的大脑刺激干预措施。她在经颅磁刺激、电休克疗法和磁性癫痫治疗等领域开展了开创性工作。在加入美国国家心理健康研究所之前，她曾担任杜克大学精神病学与行为科学系主任，并创立并指导了杜克大学和哥伦比亚大学的大脑刺激部门。她发表了280多篇科学论文，并因其研究获得了无数奖项。我们的第二位嘉宾是戴安娜·丹妮尔，一位居住在洛杉矶的作家和公关人员。她最近在《新闻周刊》上撰写了一篇专栏文章，讲述了TMS疗法如何帮助她从难治性抑郁症和焦虑症中康复，她目前正在撰写一本回忆录，记录她与慢性偏头痛、抑郁症和焦虑症抗争的经历。感谢两位今天来到这里。谢谢。谢谢邀请我们。利森比博士，我知道你叫霍莉。我可以这样称呼你吗？好的，请便。太好了。那么，你能先简单解释一下经颅磁刺激是如何工作的吗？治疗过程中会发生什么？患者的大脑里发生了什么？当然。经颅磁刺激（TMS）是一种医疗
awards for her research. Our second guest is Diana Danielle, a writer and publicist living in Los Angeles. She recently wrote a column for Newsweek on how TMS therapy helped her heal from treatment-resistant depression and anxiety, and she's writing a memoir that recounts her experiences with chronic migraines, depression, and anxiety. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you. Thank you for having us. Dr. Listenby, I understand you go by Holly. Is it okay if I call you that? Yes, please do. Great. So could you start us off by giving a brief explanation of how transcranial magnetic stimulation works? What happens during treatment? What's happening in the patient's brain? Certainly. So transcranial magnetic stimulation, or TMS, is a medical
程序，我们通过电磁线圈向头部输送磁场。线圈放置在头部，它会产生一个非常强大但短暂的磁场，并且这个磁场会非常迅速地开启和关闭。磁场的这种快速变化会在大脑中诱发微小的电脉冲，我们可以非常精确地聚焦于大脑中应用电刺激的位置。这使我们能够刺激大脑的特定区域，从而治疗抑郁症等严重疾病背后的神经回路。那么我们知道它为什么有效吗？嗯，我们对它的作用机制了解很多。目前的普遍理论认为，TMS通过靶向大脑中与抑郁症有关的分布式网络来发挥作用。
procedure where we deliver magnetic fields to the head using an electromagnetic coil. The coil is held on the head, and it induces a very strong but brief magnetic field, and that magnetic field is turned on and off very rapidly. This rapid change in the magnetic field induces tiny electrical pulses in the brain, and we can focus very precisely where in the brain the electrical stimulation is being applied. And what this allows us to do is stimulate specific regions of the brain in order to treat the circuitry underlying serious conditions like depression. So do we know why it works? Well, we know a lot about what it does. And prevailing theories are that TMS works by targeting distributed networks within the brain that are implicated in depression.
我们通过使用神经影像工具（如磁共振成像或功能性磁共振成像，即MRI）以及其他成像工具（如正电子发射断层扫描或PET）了解了与抑郁症相关的网络。利用这些工具，文献中关于抑郁症背后大脑回路的研究揭示了大脑的特定区域，例如左额叶皮层，也就是大脑左前部，以及大脑中相连的区域，即所谓的边缘回路，它涉及大脑的其他区域，帮助人们调节情绪和应对压力的韧性等。
So we learned about networks involved in depression by using neuroimaging tools like magnetic resonance imaging or functional magnetic resonance imaging or MRI, also other imaging tools like positron emission tomography or pet. And what we've learned from the literature about the brain circuits underlying depression using those tools implicated specific regions of the brain, such as the left frontal cortex, So basically on the left front part of the brain, as well as connected regions within the brain, an area of the brain called the limbic circuit, which involves other regions of the brain, that help people modulate their moods and their resilience to stress and things like that.
因此，通过靶向这些区域，TMS似乎能够改变这些回路的功能。这一证据来自影像学研究，这些研究在患者使用TMS治疗抑郁症前后进行了MRI扫描。这些研究确实表明，TMS不仅能改善情绪，还能通过调节这些回路的功能来缓解焦虑并治疗强迫症（OCD）等其他疾病。那么，戴安娜，你能告诉我们你的故事吗？你是怎么尝试TMS疗法的？
So by targeting these regions, TMS seems to be able to change the functioning of these circuits. The evidence for that comes from imaging studies where the effibanky, MRI was done before and after treatment for depression using TMS. And these studies do suggest that not only does TMS improve mood and also can alleviate anxiety and treat other conditions like obsessive-compulsive disorder or OCD by modifying the functioning of these circuits. So, Diana, can you tell us your story? How did you come to try TMS therapy?
对你来说感觉如何？嗯，我尝试自我疗愈已经快四年了。随着时间的推移，心理药物和心理咨询都没有带来任何缓解，我陷入的深渊就越深。而当你陷得越深，你就越没有能力为自己争取或寻找其他出路。但我很幸运，因为我的一位好朋友，也是我的邻居，曾患有产后抑郁症（PPD），她曾去洛杉矶的一位精神科医生梅里尔·斯帕拉戈博士那里就诊，她当时甚至不知道这叫什么。
And what was it like for you? Well, I had been, it had been almost four years that I had been trying to heal myself. And every year that passed with the psych meds and the therapy and without any alleviation, the kind of deeper I got into the hole. And then the deeper you are in the hole, the less able you are to advocate for yourself or to find something else. But I was fortunate because a dear girlfriend, who's also a neighbor, had had PPD post-partum depression, and she'd gone to a psychiatrist in Los Angeles, Dr. Meryl Sparago, and she didn't know what it was called.
她不知道它是如何工作的，但她说这是一种非药物疗法。我想他能帮到你。于是她坚持给他的办公室打电话，因为当时该诊所不对外开放。我是那里唯一的非孕妇患者，因为他的目标群体是产前或产后抑郁的女性，她们因为怀孕或哺乳不能服用药物。所以他使用了TMS机器。我和丈夫一起去了，他说，我认为你是合适的候选人。我当时想，哦不，这就像另一种新的抗抑郁药。他带我们穿过走廊，打开门，解释了它是如何工作的。它看起来像一把牙科
She didn't know how it worked, but she said it's non-drug. And I think he can help you. So she persistently called his office because it was closed to patients. And so I was the only, like, non-pregnant woman because his, you know, market is people who are depressed before, after they give birth, and they can't take drugs because of, you know, he's, you know, being pregnant or nursing. And so he uses his TMS machine. So I went in with my husband and he said, I think you're a candidate and I thought, oh, no, it's like another, you know, new antidepressant. And he walked us down the hall, opened the door, explained how it worked. It looked like a dental
椅子，上面伸出一个机械臂。我的保险覆盖了这项治疗。我做了六周。这是一种缓慢而稳定的好转过程。现在我感觉好多了，我认识的每个人都说我现在的状态是110%。对我来说，我每个月回去一次，就像买一份保险。我每个月去一次以保持这种状态。霍莉，我不太确定是否有关于这是否有效的相关研究。但我确实从中受益了。我在2018年康复了，现在已经五年了。嗯，这就引出了一个问题。霍莉，请问TMS的效果能持续多久？也就是说，人们是否需要像戴安娜刚才解释的那样回去进行某种“调优”？嗯，采取某种形式的治疗来防止抑郁症复发是很重要的。
chair with like a arm coming out of it. And my insurance covered it. And I did it for six weeks. And it was like a slow, steady getting better. And now I'm like 100. everybody I knows is I'm like 110%. And for me, I go back once a month as like an insurance policy. Like I go once a month to try to keep it going. I don't have any like, you know, there aren't any studies, Holly, about whether that works or not. I'm not sure. But it's worked for me. I got better in 2018. And so now it's been five years. Well, that raises the question. Then, Holly, let me ask you how long do TMS effects last? I mean, do. Does one have to go back for sort of a tune-up like Diana just explained? Well, it is important to be on some form of therapy to prevent the depression from coming back.
不同的人有不同的做法。研究表明，像戴安娜的经历一样，以间隔的方式继续进行TMS疗程（在你的情况下是每月一次，对有些人来说可能是每两周一次）有助于防止抑郁症复发。然而，对另一些人来说，药物本身可能就足以防止抑郁症复发。我们研究过药物结合TMS的减量和维持治疗。这确实有助于长期维持缓解状态。
And different people do it differently. Studies suggest that like Diana's experience, that continuing to get TMS sessions on a spaced out, you know, a matter, in your case, once a month, for some people, it might be every two weeks or something like that, that can help prevent the depression from coming back. For other people, though, medications may be effective on their own to prevent the depression from coming back. And that is what we studied, a combination of medications as well as kind of a tapering off and maintenance form of the TMS. And this does help to sustain remission over the long term.
研究观察了六个月、一年、两年，甚至更长时间，发现这些策略能很好地维持疗效。我认为这里重要的一点是，如果你停止TMS治疗，又不采取任何其他措施，不吃药，不进行心理咨询，也不继续TMS治疗，那么抑郁症复发的风险就相当高。因此，制定预防复发的策略非常重要。那么，TMS还被批准治疗哪些其他疾病？霍莉，我刚才听到你提到了强迫症。是的。
Studies have looked at six months, a year, two years, some even longer, finding good maintenance of benefit with these strategies. I think the important point here is if you stop the TMS and go on nothing, no medication, no form of therapy, no continued TMS, then the risk of the depression coming back is pretty high. So it's really important to have a strategy to prevent relapse. Now, what other conditions is TMS approved to treat? I heard you mention obsessive-compulsive disorder a moment ago, Holly. Right.
所以强迫症（OCD）是获批的适应症之一，针对特定类型和位置的TMS。它不仅仅是TMS，还结合了某种形式的暴露疗法。两者是同步进行的。暴露疗法激活大脑中与强迫症相关的回路，然后立即进行TMS治疗。所以这是一种协同效应。
So obsessive-compulsive disorder are OCD. That is one of the approved indications. for specific type and location of TMS. And it's not just the TMS, but it's combined with a form of exposure therapy. So the two are given in tandem. The exposure therapy activates circuits in the brain that are related to OCD, and then the treatment is applied right away. So it's sort of a synergistic effect.
它也被发现对抑郁症患者的焦虑症状有帮助。我们知道焦虑和抑郁往往是相伴而生的。它还被批准用于帮助人们戒烟。所以对于那些试图戒烟的人来说，这也有所帮助。至于未来的其他适应症，目前有很多研究正在进行，探索TMS在各种应用中的效果，例如治疗疼痛和其他适应症，我可以详细谈谈。但我目前提到的都是目前已获批的主要适应症。
It's also been found to be helpful in anxiety symptoms in people with depression. We know that anxiety and depression can really go hand in hand. It's also been approved to help people stop smoking. So people who are trying to stop smoking, this has been helpful as well. Now, in terms of other future indications, there are a lot of studies underway looking at TMS for a variety of applications, such as treating pain and other indications, which I could talk more about. but what I've mentioned so far are the main ones that are currently approved today.
我应该指出，它目前仅获批用于成年人。这是一个巨大的缺口，因为我们知道儿童和青少年也会患上抑郁症、焦虑症和强迫症，他们确实需要有效的治疗。因此，这仍然是一个活跃的研究领域，旨在观察这种疗法对于经历这些疾病的年轻人是否安全有效。戴安娜，让我问你，你经历过任何副作用吗？我听说有些人治疗后会头痛。你有过类似的情况吗？你可能会有轻微的头痛。
And I should point out it's only approved for adults. And that's a big gap because we know that children and adolescents can suffer from depression and anxiety and OCD and really need effective treatment. So that remains an area of active research to see if this can be safe and effective for young people who are experiencing these conditions. Diana, let me ask you, have you experienced any side effect? I understand that some people get headaches afterwards. Have you had anything like that? You can get a light headache.
我从来没有过，但我对头痛的耐受力很强。在陷入抑郁和焦虑的泥潭之前，我曾忍受了五年漫长的慢性偏头痛。抑郁症是它的共病。所以我治好了慢性偏头痛。自2014年以来我再没犯过偏头痛。我没有任何副作用。那么，霍莉，TMS的获取难度大吗？
I never have, but I'm pretty tough on headaches. Before I, you know, kind of slipped down the slope of depression and anxiety, I had suffered for five long years with chronic migraine. And a comorbidity of that is depression. So I was cured from the chronic migraine. I haven't had a migraine since 2014. I haven't had anything. So, Holly, how difficult is TMS to access?
它在大多数地区都能获得吗？我的意思是，我知道这些机器非常昂贵。很多精神科医生都有吗？我想说，这些年来获取途径一直在增加。请记住，它在2008年就获得了FDA批准。所以它已经存在相当长一段时间了。它并不像人们想象的那么新。因此，获取途径一直在扩大。
Is it available in most areas? I mean, I understand that the machines are quite expensive. Do many psychiatrists have them? I would say that the access has been increasing over the years. Remember, this was approved by the FDA in 2008. So it's been around for quite a while. It's not like it's, you know, that new. And so access has been expanding.
你知道，全国有些地区的获取途径可能比其他地区多，但我认为它确实在增长。有一些代表TMS提供者的组织，你可以访问他们的网站，查看你所在的州是否有附近的提供者。这张地图随着时间的推移确实在不断扩大。所以我认为它正在增加。但我必须说，我们还有很长的路要走，才能真正满足我们国家的心理健康需求，不仅是在TMS的获取方面，而且是在不同人口群体、不同保险类型的人群，或者那些参加医疗保险（Medicare/Medicaid）或没有保险的人群之间实现公平获取。所以我们确实面临挑战，但情况一直在改善。保险通常覆盖吗？我的意思是，如果精神科医生给你开了处方，
And, you know, there's some regions of the country where access might be more than others, but I think it's really growing. There are organizations that represent TMS providers, and you can go to their website to find whether there's a provider near you in whatever state that you're living. And that map has really been growing over time. So I would say that it is increasing. But we have a far way to go, though, I have to say, to really meet the mental health needs of our nation, not only with respect to access to TMS, but also equitable access across different demographic groups, across people with different types of insurance or those who are on Medicare or Medicaid or maybe uninsured. So we do have challenges, but it has been improving over time. Does insurance typically cover it? I mean, if it's prescribed to you by a psychiatrist,
你的保险公司会拒绝吗？嗯，我可以回答这个问题，也许戴安娜也想分享她的个人经历，但我可以说，支付方关注的一点是，这是否是获批的适应症？他们会评估这是否在医学上是合理的。这种评估可能是逐案进行的，但总的来说，他们会希望看到你已经尝试过其他治疗方法，其他药物治疗，并且在转向TMS之前这些方法无效。
will your insurance company fight it? Well, I can answer that, and maybe Dana would want to give her personal experience, but I could say that one of the things that the payers look for is, is this an improved indication? And they look for whether it's medically justified. And that evaluation can be on a case-by-case basis, but generally speaking, they would want to see that you have tried other treatments, other medication treatments, and that they weren't effective before then moving on to TMS.
但我还是请戴安娜来回答，因为她有个人经验。是的。我们在获得保险覆盖方面没有任何问题，因为我几乎尝试了四年各种各样的药物，抗精神病药、抗焦虑药、不同的抗抑郁药，比如SSRIs。所以，我真希望我能早点发现自己是难治性的，那样我在抑郁两年后就可以接受治疗了。但我甚至不知道这个术语，直到我有了自杀倾向，最终住进了加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）神经精神病学
But I defer to Diana because she has personal experience with this. Yes. And we didn't have any problem getting our insurance to cover it because I had almost four years of taking like everything under the sun, anti-psychotics, anti-anxiety, different, like the now antidepressant, the SSRI. So, yeah, so I wish that I would have found out that I would have found out that I were. was treatment resistant like I still could have had it after two years of depression. But I didn't even know that term until after I was suicidal and I ended up in the psych ward at UCLA Neuropsychiatric
医院。那里的医生宣布我为难治性抑郁症。我的丈夫来了。我们进行了交谈，他们紧急建议进行电休克疗法（ECT）。我还在住院期间就做了前两次治疗。但遗憾的是，它对我没有帮助。所以我去找了我的精神科医生，因为TMS确实帮到了我。我有一位很棒的精神科医生。我非常忠诚。她确实一直支持我。但我的朋友说，你必须去看斯帕拉戈博士。所以我感到很内疚，但我还是去看了他。然后我问她，她帮了我很多其他事情，职业治疗，加州大学洛杉矶分校的门诊。为什么你没告诉我这个？
hospital. And my physicians there pronounced me treatment resistant. And they, my husband came in. We had our talk and they urgently recommended electroconvulsive therapy. And I did my first two treatments while still an inpatient. But sadly, it didn't help me. So I then went to my psychiatrist because the TMS did help me. And I had a great psychiatrist. I'm very loyal. She had really supported me. But my friend said, you have to see Dr. Sprague. So I felt guilty, but I went to see him. And then I asked her, she helped me with so many other things, occupational therapy, the UCLA outpatient. Why did you tell me about it? it. So Holly, she so smart, but didn't realize, she said ECT is more effective. So then the statistics
霍莉，她很聪明，但没有意识到，她说ECT更有效。所以统计数据是支持TMS的。所以我没告诉你TMS。我知道它，因为如果ECT都没用，TMS肯定也没用。所以我回到斯帕拉戈博士那里，他说它们就像苹果和橘子。它们在不同的功能上起作用，大脑的不同部分，一个是诱发癫痫，一个是轻微刺激。所以我觉得如果更多的医生知道这一点会很好。因为如果还有其他精神科医生认为如果我做了ECT，TMS就不会起作用怎么办？这是真的吗，霍莉？我很乐意回答这个问题。我认为你的经历，戴安娜，对于帮助我们理解如何为每个人匹配正确的治疗方法非常重要，而不仅仅是考虑人群。
were TMS. So I didn't tell you about TMS. I do know about it because if ECT didn't work, TMS never would. So I went back to Dr. Sprague and he said they're like apples and oranges. They're working in different functions, different parts of the brain seizing it versus like tapping on it. And so I feel like it would be great if more doctors knew that. because what if there are other psychiatrists who think that if I did ECT, TMS wouldn't work? Is that true, Holly? So I'm happy to respond to that. I think that your experience, Dana, is very important to help us understand how we need to match the right treatment for each individual person and not just think about, you know, groups of people.
文献确实表明，对于一部分人来说，ECT的反应率往往高于TMS。但这并不意味着这对每个人都适用。在你的案例中，情况并非如此。TMS有效，而ECT无效。所以我认为这是我们领域的一个挑战。如果我们能有一种测试，某种工具，能让我们找出哪种治疗方法对你有效，戴安娜，并在你遭受多年抑郁折磨之前就给你提供这种治疗，那将非常有帮助。这种疾病对你的生活有如此严重的影响，甚至可能危及生命，正如你提到的，
Now, the literature does show that for a group of people, the ECT, tends to have a higher response rate than TMS. But that doesn't mean that's going to be true for every single person. And in your case, it wasn't true. The TMS was effective, whereas the ECT wasn't. So I think that this is a challenge in our field. It would be so helpful if we had a test, some sort of tool that we could use to figure out which treatment is going to work for you, Diana, and to be able to give that to you before you have had to suffer for years. with depression that was not remitting. And to have such severe impacts on your life, it can be life-threatening, as you mentioned,
在研究领域开发这些工具以使我们能够在正确的时间为正确的人提供正确的治疗是一个挑战。这是一个局限性。但我们正在支持相关研究以试图解决这个问题。阿门。现在，电休克疗法（ECT）的公众形象有点，怎么说呢，不太好。我们很多人都看过《飞越疯人院》，那是我们对接受ECT治疗的人的印象。我想问你，霍莉，这种印象准确、公平吗？现在的ECT是什么样的？它是否比我们被引导相信的更有效？我的意思是，很多人谈论过在接受ECT后记忆力减退的问题。我很乐意回答这个问题。
it's a challenge in the research field to develop those tools so that we can bring the right treatment to the right person at the right time. That is a limitation. But we are supporting research to try to address that. Amen. Now, electroconvulsive therapy has a, a bit of, shall I say, a poor public image. A lot of us are old enough to have seen one flew over the cuckoo's nest, and that's our image of what happens to people who get ECT. I want to ask you, Holly, is that accurate, fair? What is ECT like these days? And is it more effective than we have been led to believe? I mean, a lot of people have talked about losing their memory, for example, after going through ECT. So I'm happy to respond to that.
而且，戴安娜，你有接受ECT的亲身经历。所以我们也想听听你的声音。我可以从精神科医生的角度告诉你，我曾进行过ECT治疗，也有过治疗前、治疗中和治疗后的患者，根据文献，ECT是非常有效的，特别是在药物不起作用的情况下。通常在TMS无效时，以及当一个人需要非常迅速的反应时，例如他们可能有结束生命的念头并有自杀风险。此外，对于患有精神病性抑郁症的个体，他们可能会听到声音或产生妄想，这是一种非常危险的抑郁症。
And also, Dana, you have lived experience with having ECT. So we want to hear your voice on that, too. I can tell you that from my perspective as a psychiatrist, having given ECT and had patients before, during, and after, and based on the literature, ECT is highly effective, especially in situations where medications aren't working. often when TMS doesn't work, and when a person is in need of very rapid response, such as they may be having thoughts of wanting to in their life and be at risk for suicide. Also in individuals who have psychotic subtype of depression where they may be hearing voices or having delusions is a very dangerous form of depression.
至于公众形象，它是由像《飞越疯人院》这样的虚构作品塑造的，那是虚构的。现代ECT与那毫无相似之处。首先，它是在麻醉下进行的。你在手术过程中是睡着的。手术过程中没有疼痛。你是无意识的。你在全身麻醉下受到医生的监护。治疗持续不到几分钟。
Now, in terms of the public image, which has been shaped by fictional portrayals like cuckoo's nest, which is, which was fiction. modern ECT bears no resemblance to that. First of all, it's done under anesthesia. You're asleep for the procedure. There's no pain during the procedure. You're unconscious. You are being monitored by doctors under general anesthesia. The treatment lasts less than a couple of minutes.
确实，ECT有副作用，记忆力减退是一个非常重要的副作用。但通过现代ECT，我们改进了治疗方法，包括电极在头部的放置位置以及电量。这些改进极大地减少了，尽管尚未完全消除，ECT导致记忆力减退的风险。我也是一名曾被ECT挽救生命的患者的家属。所以我既作为家属也作为医生，是这种疗法的信徒。但我真的很想听听你的故事，戴安娜，因为你亲身经历过？是的。当时，自从我做了这个之后，我查了ECT。有一本很棒的书，
And it is true that there are side effects from ECT, memory loss being a very important one. But with modern ECT, we've modified the treatment in terms of where the electronic are placed on the head and how much electricity is given. And these modifications have dramatically reduced, although not yet eliminated, the risk of memory loss with ECT. I am also a family member of a person whose life was saved by ECT. So I'm a believer in this, both as a family member and as a physician. But I'm really interested to hear your story, Deanna, because you personally experienced this? Yes. And at the time, it's since I've done this, I looked up ECT. There's a great book by,
作者是已故的凯丽·费雪，她写了一本书，讲述了ECT对她来说就像救命稻草，正如TMS对我一样。而且，在疫情期间，我和丈夫在看克莱尔·丹妮丝主演的《国土安全》。她在剧中患有双相情感障碍，这是剧情的一部分。剧中展示了她接受ECT治疗，他们把那个东西放在你嘴里，这样你就不会咬断舌头。我当时就像得了创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），因为当我躺在那里准备被麻醉时，我看不见自己。我看到了医生眼中的我。这对我来说仍然有点可怕。我听说过一个女人忘记了她的婚礼。所以我进去时知道有失去记忆的风险。对我来说发生的事情是，
she's now past Carrie Fisher, wrote a book about how ECT, it was like, TMS is to me as ECT was to her, like a lifesaver. And also on, I was just watching with my husband during the pandemic in the show Homeland with Claire Daines. She has bipolar in the show and it's part of the storyline. She under, show her undergoing ECT and then they put that thing in your mouth so you don't bite your tongue off. And I was like getting like PTSD because when I was laying there about to be put under, I can't see myself. I saw myself as the doctor saw me. And it still was a little scary for me. And so I had heard of a woman who forgot her wedding day. So I went in and I knew there was a chance of losing memory. What happened for me is,
我每周做一次，持续了大约两个月。到第七次和第八次时，我醒来时不知道发生了什么。我知道我在医院。但我不知道我的名字。我有一种爬行的感觉，不知道我在哪里。我非常、非常、非常困惑。这很诡异。
I did it for about two months once a week. And by the seventh and eighth time that I did it, I was waking up and I didn't know. I knew I was in the hospital. I didn't know my name. I had this feeling of this crawling thing about where I am. I was very, very, very confused. It was creepy.
此外，它对我并没有真正起作用。所以我告诉丈夫，我要退出了。这不是适合我的东西。那么，霍莉，有没有人是不适合TMS的候选人？我们考虑谁可能从TMS中受益，谁可能更容易出现副作用。让我从谁可能受益开始。所以，标签上的适应症，如抑郁症、焦虑症、强迫症，在一个人尝试了至少几种药物之后，这些都是很好的候选人。我认为副作用的担忧，那些容易出现
And in addition, it wasn't really helping me. And so I told my husband, I'm quitting. This is not the thing for me. So, Holly, are there individuals who would be poor candidates, let's say, for TMS? So we think about who is TMS likely to benefit and who is TMS likely to have more side effects with. So let me start with who is likely to benefit. So the labeled indications such as depression, anxiety, OCD, after a person has tried at least several medications. those would be good candidates. I think the concern of side effects, people who would be
严重副作用的人，可能是患有癫痫的人。所以TMS最严重的已知副作用是癫痫发作。因此，如果一个人患有癫痫等癫痫疾病，或者如果一个人因为脑肿瘤或其他脑损伤（例如多发性硬化症或MS）而有癫痫发作的风险，或者可能是中风过的人，这些都会导致脑损伤，从而使该人在使用TMS时面临更高的癫痫发作风险。因此，当我们评估一个人时，我们会看获益的可能性有多大？然后我们会筛查他们是否存在可能增加TMS不良副作用风险的因素。那么，每个人的大脑都一样吗？
vulnerable to significant side effects, would be people who have epilepsy. So the most serious known side effect of TMS is seizure. So if a person has a seizure disorder like epilepsy, or if a person has a risk for seizure because they have a brain tumor or other brain lesion that might be, for example, from multiple sclerosis or MS, or maybe someone who's had a stroke, these things cause brain lesions that could put that person at more risk of seizure with TMS. And so when we evaluate people, we look at what's the lot of likelihood of benefit? And then we screen them for risk factors that might increase their chance of having an adverse side effect from TMS. Now, is everybody's brain the same?
因为当你把磁铁放在人们头上时，你怎么知道你是在为那个人找到正确的位置？霍莉，你提到了在左侧大脑，左撇子和右撇子有区别吗？这是一个非常好的问题。每个人的大脑都是不同的。事实上，每个人的大脑都不同。甚至你自己的大脑随着时间的推移也会改变，对吧？
Because when you're putting the magnets on people's heads, how do you know that? that you're in exactly the right spot for the right person. And you mentioned, Holly, I think going on the left side of the brain, is it different for left-handed people versus right-handed people? That's such a great question. And everyone's brain is different. And in fact, everyone's brain is different. Even your own brain over time changes, right?
所以在TMS的早期，我们没有很好的工具来个性化放置TMS的位置。我们的工具实际上是一把卷尺。我们会找到大脑中会导致手部抽搐的区域，那就是手部区域。然后我们会用卷尺测量它前面五到六厘米的地方。我们称之为前额叶皮层或“甜蜜点”。现在我们有了更好的工具。
And so in the early days of TMS, we did not have great tools to personalize where the TMS was being placed. Our tool was literally a tape measure. We would find the area of the brain that would cause a twitch in the hand, so that's the hand area. And then we would use a tape measure and measure five or six centimeters in front of that. We called that the prefrontal cortex or sweet spot. Now we have better tools.
事实上，有一种新的方案叫做“圣人方案”（Saint Protocol），用于斯坦福加速TMS。它的做法是进行脑部扫描。所以每个人都会接受脑部扫描，使用功能性磁共振成像。该脑部扫描用于确定该人在前额叶皮层中适合的位置，该位置连接到我们认为对抑郁症很重要的分布式大脑区域网络。
And in fact, there's a new protocol called the Saint Protocol, which is for Stanford Accelerated TMS. And what that does is you get a brain scan. So each person gets their brain scanned, use. functional magnetic resonance imaging. And that brain scan is used to determine the right spot for that person in the prefrontal cortex that taps into the network of distributed brain areas that we think are important for depression.
这种方法可能更有效地为每个人量身定制治疗方案。戴安娜，你刚开始时有什么问题吗？比如，他们找到正确的位置了吗？他找到了我的“甜蜜点”。是的，我的意思是，那不是“圣人方案”。我一直与斯坦福大脑刺激实验室的负责人诺兰·威廉姆斯博士保持联系，是他做的那个研究。他非常想告诉我，他们甚至没有在研究中招募“容易治疗”的人。他们招募的是难治性患者，因为有时在研究中，你想要招募那些容易康复的健康人。
And that approach may be more effective to tailor the treatment for each individual person. Were there any issues for you, Diana, when you first started? Like, did they land on the right spot? He had my sweet spot. Yeah, I mean, it wasn't the one, the saint. I have been in touch with Dr. Nolan Williams, who was the head at the brain stimulation lab at Stanford, who did that. And he was very really wanted to tell me that they didn't even take like easy people for that study. They took treatment resistant people, you know, because sometimes when there are studies, you want to get like a good, healthy people that could be helped.
但他们做的是那些病情非常严重的人。所以我认为这非常令人兴奋。而且，霍莉，因为人们，比如我当时很幸运，我丈夫在工作。我没有工作。而且我有育儿帮助。所以我能够坚持六周。现在，对于工作的人来说，六周几乎是不可能的，除非他们申请残疾。而那些工作且需要育儿帮助，又负担不起的人……
but they were doing people that were really hard. So I think that's very exciting. And also, Holly, because people, like I was privileged, my husband worked. I wasn't working. And I had child care. So I was able to do six weeks. Now, six weeks for people who work is almost impossible unless they took disability. And people who work and need child care and couldn't afford the, you know what I mean?
所以对于某些人来说存在障碍。现在他们可以在五天内完成，新闻文章中的一个人，他是一名工程师，抑郁多年。然后他能够请一周假。他和他们一起做了五天。他说，你知道，在我来这里之前，我宁愿把针扎进眼睛里也不愿去上班。现在我迫不及待地想去告诉每个人我的感受。所以这真的很棒。
So there's like barriers for certain people. now that they can do it in five days, one of the men that was in the press article, he was an engineer who'd been depressed for years. And then he was able to get a week off work. He did the five days with them. And he said, you know, before I got here, I'd rather stick my needle in my eye than go to work. And now I can't wait to go and tell everyone how I feel. So that was really great.
我认为让人们更容易获得这种治疗，就像你谈到的各个层面的可及性，但这是该方案的另一个问题。如果我们能把它缩短成那样，你知道，然后那些获得专利的人，他们正试图把它引入精神病院和急诊室，用于急性自杀倾向。霍莉，我想问你一个关于更具侵入性的大脑刺激疗法的问题，因为我知道有些疗法涉及在大脑中植入电极。这项研究的现状如何？是的，你指的是深部脑刺激（DBS）。
And I think that this making it more accessible to people, like you were talking about accessibility on all these different levels, but this is another problem with the protocol. If we can shrink it like that, you know, and then the people that got the patent, they're trying to get it into psych wards and emergency rooms for acute suicidality. Let me ask you a question, Holly, about more invasive brain stimulation treatments, because I understand that there are some that involve implanting electrodes in the brain. What's the state of that research? Yes, you're referring to deep brain stimulation or DBS.
我实际上参与了一些研究DBS治疗抑郁症的试验。我们现在也在资助这方面的研究。该手术涉及在大脑深部区域植入小电极。所以这是一台手术。这是一台脑部手术。这就是为什么它被称为侵入性的。它确实有脑部手术的风险，包括出血或感染的风险。但我们实际上在以安全有效的方式进行深部脑刺激方面有很多经验，
And I actually have been part of some of those trials that examined DBS for depression. And also we're now funding new studies on this. So the procedure involves implanting small electrodes into deep regions of the brain. So this is a surgery. It's a brain surgery. So that's why it's called invasive. It does have the risks of brain surgery, which include the risk of bleeding or infection. But we actually have a lot of experience doing deep brain stimulation in other conditions in a safe and effective matter,
例如用于帕金森病和某些运动障碍，DBS已获得FDA批准，确实改变了帕金森病患者的护理，这是一种非常重要且可能致残的疾病。DBS确实能够恢复帕金森病患者的功能和生活质量。因此，人们寄予厚望，随着我们对抑郁症背后神经回路的了解加深，DBS可以适应其他疾病，如抑郁症和强迫症。事实上，对于强迫症，DBS治疗已经获得了一种FDA批准，称为人道主义设备豁免（HDE）。这意味着强迫症是一种罕见
such as for Parkinson's disease and certain movement disorders, where DBS is FDA approved and really has transformed the care for people with Parkinson's disease, which is a very important and can be disabling disorder. DBS really has been able to restore function and quality of life for people with Parkinson's disease. So there's a great hope that as we learn more about the circuitry underlying depression, that DBS could be adapted to other conditions like depression and obsessive-compulsive disorder. In fact, OCD, there is a type of FDA approval already for the DBS. treatment of OCD, and it's called a humanitarian device exemption or HDE. It means OCD is a rare
疾病，这种人道主义设备豁免允许FDA批准针对这些罕见疾病的治疗。现在，关于DBS治疗抑郁症的研究现状，不幸的是，已经有两项主要的行业赞助的DBS治疗抑郁症的试验未能发现其有效性，我参与了其中一项试验。但这并不是故事的终点。我们已经学到了很多关于如何使治疗更加个性化，如何为每个人找到正确的位置，就像我们谈论为TMS找到正确位置一样。同样的情况也适用于DBS。此外，最近令人兴奋的研究一直在使用植入的电极来发现大脑活动随时间变化的模式，这些模式可以被用来
condition, and this humanitarian device exemption allows the FDA to approve a treatment for these rare conditions. Now, the state of research on DBS for depression, unfortunately, there have been two major industry-sponsored trials on DBS for depression that did not succeed in findings. it effective and I was part of one of those trials. But that's not the end of the story. We've learned a lot about how to make the treatment more individualized, how to find the right spot for each person, just like we were talking about finding the right spot for TMS. The same really goes also for DBS. And also exciting research recently has been using implanted electrodes to discover the temporal pattern of brain activity changes over time that can be used.
触发刺激，以便在每个人需要的时间和地点进行刺激。我提到的这些研究得到了美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）大脑计划的支持，这是一项由白宫发起的计划，旨在真正改变我们研究和治疗抑郁症和强迫症等大脑疾病的方式。我们非常期待目前正在进行的这些更先进的调节大脑回路方法的试验结果。我们将在未来几年看到这些研究的结果。霍莉，你知道我问过你关于TMS和ECT的对比。如果你要治疗抑郁症，比如如果TMS对我无效，那么我会被排除在深部脑刺激（DBS）之外吗？
to trigger the stimulation so that the stimulation is being given when and where it's needed for each person. Now, these studies I'm referring to are being supported by the National Institute of Health Brain Initiative, which was a White House sponsored initiative to really transform the way we study and treat brain disorders like depression and OCD. And we're really looking forward to the results of the studies that are currently underway with these more advanced approaches to tuning brain circuits. And we will see the results of those studies in the coming years. You know how I asked you, Holly, about TMS versus ECT. What are the ways, like if you're going to treat depression, like if TMS didn't work for me, would then I be ruled out of the deep brain stimulation,
还是说它们完全不同，你可以尝试所有方法？是的，这是一个很好的问题。每项研究都有不同的纳入和排除标准，但我可以说我参与的那项研究，通常你会希望看到该人已经尝试过侵入性较小的治疗方法。这些侵入性较小的治疗方法当然可以包括TMS、药物，甚至ECT，然后你才会去参加一个需要手术和植入电极的研究。所以我们招募的大多数人之前都已经接受过ECT，其中许多人已经接受过TMS，并没有被排除在外。但同样，每项具体研究的标准都是个人的。哦，我很高兴你们这样做，因为这意味着
the DBS, or it's all different and you can try everything? Yeah, well, that's a great question. So each study has different inclusion, exclusion criteria, but I can say the study I was part of, and typically you would want to see that the person has tried less invasive approaches first. And those less invasive approaches certainly could include TMS, medications, even ECT, before you go to a study where you're getting a surgery and implanted electrodes. So most of the people that we enrolled in those studies had already had. ECT, many of them had already had TMS and did not rule them out. But again, the criteria for each specific study are, you know, individual. Oh, I'm so glad you're doing that because that means
如果他们已经经历了所有这些关卡，他们患病的时间就更长了，因为没有人会主动提供ECT或TMS。你必须长期服用药物。有时你可能早就康复了，但你甚至不知道有这种疗法，因为人们对它的认知度并不像对患者有益的那样高。让我稍微转换一下话题，谈谈一些关于人们购买家用大脑刺激设备的报道，特别是所谓的经颅直流电刺激（TDCS）。霍莉，这些有效吗？
they've had it even longer, if they've already gone through all those gates, because nobody offers you, you know, ECT or TMS. You have to be on the drugs for a long time. And sometimes you could have already been held, but you didn't even know it was there, like the awareness of it is not as high as would be beneficial for people. Let me switch gears a little bit to some reports about people buying in-home brain stimulation devices, especially something that's called a transcranial direct current stimulation or TDCS. Holly, do these work?
我的意思是，它们能治疗抑郁症吗？有些人认为它们可以提高注意力和专注力，但有任何研究支持这一点吗？所以我们现在谈论的是一种不同类型的技术，它将电流应用于头皮，不是为了诱发癫痫，而是非常微弱的电流来改变大脑活动。因此，虽然TMS应用磁场来诱发大脑中的微小电流，但像经颅直流电刺激（TDCS）这样的技术直接将电流应用于头皮，以诱发这些微弱电流或改变
I mean, do they treat depression? Some people think that they may improve focus and concentration, but is there any research to back that up? So we are now talking about a different type of technology that applies electrical currents to the scalp, not to induce a seizure, but very weak electrical currents to change brain activity. So whereas TMS applies magnetic fields to induce tiny electrical currents in the brain, technologies like transcranial direct current stimulation or TDCS apply electricity directly to the scalp to induce these weak currents or to change.
大脑的极化。所以我参与过研究并发表过关于TDCS治疗抑郁症的文章。有一些有希望的研究表明它可能对抑郁症有益。它确实具有非常出色的安全性。与TMS相比，TDCS没有像ECT那样诱发癫痫或记忆力减退的风险。但我可以告诉你，至少我参与的那项研究，不幸的是我们没有发现，我们没有重复出TDCS在治疗抑郁症方面有效的证据。所以我认为文献在这一点上是混合的，但就像我们谈论的其他技术一样，我们对在哪里放置TDCS电极、如何配置它们、在谁身上可能有效，这些知识都在不断发展。它仍然是一个活跃的研究领域。所以我认为TDCS类技术的一个优势是，因为它们非常安全，所以可以在家里使用。而你不会对TMS这样做，因为你需要处于有医疗监督的环境中。但TDCS是一种更便携的技术。
change polarization of the brain. So I've been part of studies and published on this TDCS for the treatment of depression. There have been some promising studies suggesting that it could have benefit in depression. It certainly has a very excellent safety profile. For one thing compared to TMS, TDCS does not have a risk of inducing seizure or memory loss like ECT. But I can tell you that at least the study I was part of, unfortunately we did not find, We did not replicate the evidence that TDCS was effective in treating depression. So I would say the literature is mixed on this point, but just like the other technologies we've
它非常便宜。所以当你想到不仅是我们国家，还有中低收入国家的全球心理健康需求时，像TDCS这样的技术如果能弄清楚如何有效地使用它们，确实会产生影响。而且，它尚未获得FDA批准，并且仍然是一个活跃的研究领域。我知道有些公司销售类似的技术作为生活方式产品，但并没有医疗声明。
been talking about, our knowledge of where to place the TDCS electrodes, how to configure them, in whom would they likely to be beneficial, is evolving. And it remains an active area of research. So I would say one of the advantages of TDCS type of technologies, because they're so safe, is that they could be used at home. Whereas you wouldn't be doing that with TMS, because you need to be in a context with medical supervision. But TDCS is a technology that's more portable.
我们一直在讨论，关于如何放置经颅直流电刺激（TDCS）电极、如何配置它们以及哪些人可能从中受益的知识正在不断演变。这仍然是一个活跃的研究领域。因此，我想说TDCS类技术的一个优势在于它们非常安全，可以在家里使用。而你不会对经颅磁刺激（TMS）这样做，因为你需要处于有医疗监督的环境中。但TDCS是一种更便携的技术。
It's very cheap. So when you think about the global mental health needs of not just our nation, but low-and-middle-income countries, technologies like TDCS could really have an impact. if we can figure out how to use them effectively. And that is, it's not yet FDA approved and it continues to be an active area of research. I do know that there are companies that sell similar technologies as lifestyle products, but not with medical claims.
它非常便宜。因此，当你考虑到不仅是我们国家，还有中低收入国家的全球心理健康需求时，像TDCS这样的技术如果能弄清楚如何有效使用，确实可以产生影响。目前它尚未获得FDA批准，并且仍然是一个活跃的研究领域。我确实知道有些公司将类似的技术作为生活方式产品销售，但并没有声称其具有医疗用途。
It's popular in the gaming community as a way of increasing focus or attention, like you mentioned. But if a person has depression, that's a significant medical illness. they really should see a doctor, see a therapist, see a clinician to evaluate them and then to have a treatment plan that is clinically appropriate. Well, that makes sense. So what's next on the research horizon? Holly, what else are you working on and what else might TMS be able to treat at some point? So one of the things that we've learned about TMS is that the effect of TMS on the brain
正如你所提到的，它在游戏社区中很受欢迎，被视为一种提高专注力或注意力的方法。但如果一个人患有抑郁症，那是一种严重的医学疾病。他们真的应该去看医生、看治疗师或临床医生，进行评估，然后制定临床上合适的治疗方案。嗯，这很有道理。那么研究的前景如何呢？Holly，你还在研究什么？TMS在未来还有可能治疗什么疾病？我们对TMS了解的一点是，TMS对大脑的影响
depends on what the brain is doing at the time you're being stimulated. So, for example, if you think about moving your hand, when we stimulate the hand air of your brain, we get a larger response in your hand. So we're generalizing that concept to try to combine psychotherapy with TMS. The way this works is we administer a form of cognitive behavioral therapy while the person is getting TMS.
取决于你在接受刺激时大脑正在做什么。例如，如果你想移动你的手，当我们刺激你大脑中控制手的区域时，你的手会有更强烈的反应。因此，我们正在推广这一概念，试图将心理治疗与TMS相结合。其工作原理是，在患者接受TMS治疗的同时，我们进行某种形式的认知行为疗法。
We target this based on functional MRI to try to target networks of brain areas that are involved in the particular types of cognitive functions that the therapy is tapping into. And so this, we're looking for a synergistic effect and really a merger between psychotherapeutic approaches and brain stimulation approaches. You could think of it as using the TMS to boost learning, to boost plasticity of the brain, that then the therapy can take advantage of. So that's one direction, and we're actively enrolling in a study with this combination.
我们根据功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）来定位大脑区域网络，这些区域与治疗所涉及的特定认知功能有关。因此，我们正在寻求一种协同效应，真正实现心理治疗方法与脑刺激方法的融合。你可以把它想象成利用TMS来促进学习，增强大脑的可塑性，然后治疗就可以利用这一点。这就是一个方向，我们正在积极招募参与这项联合治疗研究的受试者。
We're also trying to re-engineer ECT to make it safer. And we have a number of ways of doing that. You mentioned one using magnetic stimulation to induce more focal and targeted seizures without as much electricity as we get in the brain with ECT. We have some other electrical approaches to doing that as well. Individualized low-amplitude seizure therapy is one where we give weak electrical currents to stimulate more localized seizures. And we have a study that is just giving electrical fields without inducing a seizure.
我们也在尝试重新设计电休克疗法（ECT），使其更安全。我们有多种方法可以做到这一点。你提到了一种利用磁刺激来诱发更局限、更有针对性的癫痫发作，而不需要像ECT那样在大脑中输入那么多的电流。我们还有其他一些实现这一目标的电气方法。个体化低振幅癫痫治疗就是其中之一，我们给予微弱的电流来刺激更局部的癫痫发作。我们还有一项研究只是施加电场而不诱发癫痫。
What we want to understand with the suite of studies is, is it the electricity or is it the seizure or both that drives the powerful clinical effects of ECT? Because by better understanding how that treatment works, we'll be better prepared to re-engineer an intervention that focuses on the benefits and avoids the side effects. So, Diana, you get the last word with us today. You definitely are sort of a walking example of how TMS can benefit people's lives. What are the prospects for you, since you're continuing to get it at least once a month? Do you feel like this is how you're going to live out your life? Yes, Kim, that is how I'm going to live out my life. That's one. Second, I must say, my daughter is 15. And when she was 13, when we were in lockdown, a friend in her friend, it wasn't her best friend, but it was her friend in the friend group. Her boyfriend broke up with her. She had a difficult home life. And she was threatening suicide. My daughter came downstairs, wild-eyed and teary, pulling at my arm. I need you. They won't talk to me on the suicide hotline because I'm under 18. So one of the biggest things I want to do with my book, besides what everybody know about TMS
我们通过这一系列研究想要了解的是，究竟是电流、癫痫发作，还是两者共同驱动了ECT强大的临床效果？因为通过更好地了解该疗法的工作原理，我们将能更好地重新设计一种干预措施，既能发挥其益处，又能避免副作用。那么，Diana，今天最后由你来总结。你绝对是一个TMS如何造福人们生活的活生生的例子。既然你至少每月还在接受一次治疗，你未来的前景如何？你觉得这就是你余生要过的生活方式吗？是的，Kim，这就是我余生要过的生活。这是第一点。第二，我必须说，我女儿15岁了。当她13岁时，我们在封锁期间，她朋友圈里的一个朋友，不是她最好的朋友，但确实是她朋友圈里的朋友。她的男朋友和她分手了。她的家庭生活很困难。她当时威胁要自杀。我女儿跑下楼，双眼通红，泪流满面，拉着我的胳膊说：我需要你。自杀热线的人不跟我说话，因为我未满18岁。所以，除了让大家都知道TMS之外，我想通过我的书做的最重要的事情之一
and how it worked for me, is to try to get TMS covered for the under 18s. For kids, because of the teen mental health crisis, you know, we keep hearing about, which is so true and which I've experienced, because, you know, most of them, except Prozac, have a black box warning. And so they don't even, you know, there's not a lot of options for kids. And I have run across TMS places in the United States. They will do it for someone under 18, but it is not covered by insurance because it's not FDA approved. And so what I would like most in life is to have the FDA approve it for under 18.
以及它对我如何起作用，就是争取让未成年人也能享受TMS保险覆盖。对于孩子们来说，因为我们一直听说的青少年心理健康危机，这是千真万确的，我也亲身经历过，因为你知道，除了百忧解（Prozac），大多数药物都有黑框警告。所以他们甚至，你知道，孩子们没有太多选择。我在美国遇到过一些TMS诊所。他们会为18岁以下的人提供治疗，但保险不予报销，因为它没有获得FDA批准。所以我一生中最想要的就是让FDA批准它用于18岁以下的人群。
I had to put that in. Just, I know I said that was the last question, but Holly, how close are we to FDA approval for kids under 18? So there was an industry-sponsored trial to try to support FDA approval of TMS and the treatment of adolescent depression. Unfortunately, that trial was not successful in demonstrating the level of efficacy that the FDA needs to see. It did show that it was safe. That's really important. But I think what this teaches us is that just back to everyone's brain is different, the brain changes over the course of development. And using an adult dose of TMS on an adolescent may not be the right strategy.
我必须插一句。我知道我刚才说那是最后一个问题，但Holly，我们距离FDA批准用于18岁以下儿童还有多远？有一个由行业赞助的试验，试图支持FDA批准TMS用于治疗青少年抑郁症。遗憾的是，该试验未能证明FDA所要求的疗效水平。它确实证明了它是安全的。这一点非常重要。但我认为这告诉我们，回到每个人的大脑都是不同的这一点，大脑在发育过程中会发生变化。对青少年使用成人剂量的TMS可能不是正确的策略。
And so I think there's a need for research on adolescent depression to really understand what is driving depression in the youth so that we can tailor the treatment to their needs rather than giving them the adult dose, which we've already seen is not effective. And that is an active area of research. So I really do encourage the researchers out there to pay attention to this area, to submit grants on this topic, and to really invest in understanding the causes of depression and suicide in youth. It's so critically important. And, Dana, you said it very well. I agree with you. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. This has been really interesting, and I appreciate both of your contributions to the this fascinating discussion today. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much. Great meeting you.
所以我认为有必要对青少年抑郁症进行研究，真正了解是什么导致了青少年的抑郁，这样我们才能根据他们的需求量身定制治疗方案，而不是给他们成人剂量，我们已经看到那是不有效的。这是一个活跃的研究领域。所以我真的鼓励研究人员关注这个领域，提交关于这个主题的资助申请，并真正投入到理解青少年抑郁和自杀原因的研究中。这至关重要。而且，Dana，你说得很好。我同意你的观点。好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我的节目。这非常有趣，我很感谢你们两位对今天这个引人入胜的讨论所做的贡献。谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢。很高兴见到你们。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher、YouTube或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condyenne。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。